[Musique]
or mon slogan c'est paris saclay était
une fois à l'innovation pour évoquer le
domaine des comptes en fait des belles
histoires qui font rêver qui inspire des
gens et l'idée de il était une fois
l'innovation c'est un appel à
l'innovation a osé un bougé l'ordre
établi à de faire parler sa clairement
un levier pour tous ceux qui veulent
agir
[Musique]
oh
paris saclay innovant ensemble au
service du vivant c'est le
c'est le moment que j'ai choisi pourquoi
parce que je suis convaincu qu il est
possible d'allier modernité évolutions
et innovations et humanisme
[Musique]
on se regarde on s'est parlé saclay une
ovation sur un plateau j'ai choisi ce
slogan parce que pour moi le plateau de
saclay est un lieu où neuf où on se
rassemble et où on partage des idées
pour l'innovation
[Musique]
on
hu
mon slogan c est paris saclay faire de
la france la plus grande nation start up
de monde parce que je suis convaincu que
l'inde lui j'ai failli saclay des
talents et des ressources pour le faire
dès leur france les plus grands tubes et
heures de surf et mondial
[Musique]
paris saclay innovation playground parce
que l'innovation est une passion et que
sans jeu il n'y a pas de passion
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]